we're debt Loomis how do newly elected
congressman become influential
representatives the answer you get time
and time again is specialized pick
something out go to work on it get your
teeth into something special on your
committee keep your nose to the
grindstone but it's not quite what it
used to be to get them along you've got
to go along a hundred percent don't talk
don't say anything for for years and
years rather if you set your priorities
and if you do decide to get go after
something you can become active very
quickly but you better know what you're
talking about and you'd better do it in
a way that won't offend large numbers of
your peers how long does it take for
congressman to become our congresswoman
to become influential someone like a
Tony Coelho has had a relatively
meteoric rise a Phil Gramm in a very
different way had a very quick rise to
prominence other folks people we may
never have heard of a bill Hughes from
New Jersey working in the vineyards of
the House Judiciary Committee extremely
influential member of Congress been at
it for thirteen fifteen years his
influence comes by working a lot more
slowly but actively toward a series of
goals IRA Chaleff is it a major problem
for new representatives to set up a
congressional office I think the answer
is emphatically yes one of the problems
is that a newly elected member doesn't
take office until the beginning of
January but the people who voted for him
or her think that that is their member
as of the day after election after the
election therefore they start
communicating to the member the member
does not yet have an office staff budget
really no effective way to respond when
they actually do take over
they are already far behind the starting
gate there's maybe twenty thousand
letters literally waiting for them
unanswered that's just the first in a
series of shocks that they will probably
receive
when you think of the problems that
congressmen face when they first get
into office for some reason setting up
that office doesn't seem to come to mind
why is that well it's very much
something that's behind the scenes you
know we're aware of the committee
hearings were aware of the floor
procedures were aware perhaps of the
member going back to the district and
talking in town meetings but except for
the handful of people who come to
Washington the average the average
constituent the average citizen is not
aware that there's a small business that
is supporting this member that there are
maybe a dozen staff in Washington we're
talking about that house of course at
this point the Senate the offices are
much larger dozen or 15 staff supporting
the member and doing a tremendously
complex range of tasks for the member
but it's behind the scenes and it has to
be because everything they do is in the
member's name they don't want to be
taking the limelight tonight we will be
focusing on the question once you get
elected what happens next
now there is help and that help is right
here setting a course it is published by
American University's Center for
congressional and presidential studies
and the Congressional Management
Foundation and our guest tonight our
contributor is in some ways will be
discussing exactly their role in putting
this book together Burdette Loomis is
chairman of the political science
department at the University of Kansas
and you originally hired by American
University to be project director for
the first edition of setting course
which was I believe published in 84
right right we started I started work
two year three years ago today and in
nine months we had the book in the
members hands when American university
first approached you what did you think
of the idea about this since I had
written a little bit academically on the
arcane world of congressional offices I
was I was very pleased it would give me
a chance to stay personally in
Washington for a year I'd do something
that I was interested in and it allowed
me to I think make a contribution in an
area that it's very difficult for the
government to tell members of Congress
to even encourage them to set their
office up one way or another they they
shy away from that the independence of
the member of Congress is very important
but someone from the outside can offer
this advice without having that kind of
onus of official sanction ira calif as
executive director of the congressional
management foundation and you were
brought in on this project by mr. Lumis
to do the second edition which is the
edition that just came up for the 100th
congress what was the big thing that you
wanted to get across because your
background is basically on congressional
management what was the main point you
wanted to get across well first of all
let me just clarify something we
actually worked with Burdette on the
first edition as well the congressional
management foundation was founded about
10 years ago by former Hills staff who
found that the workload in Congress was
skyrocketing and was outstripping their
capacity to support the constituents
expectations for the members they went
out these these folks went out and set
up the congressional management
foundation for many years the
congressional management Foundation for
6 or 7 years prior to the publication of
this book has been attempting to provide
some sort of management orientation to
newly elected members of Congress when
Burdette came along and said that he had
the resources to really do a first-rate
major study and produce a manual the
extent of setting course we were
terribly excited to be involved in the
project because it was a way that we
could really forward our mission the
book that we just showed cut back
management for congressional offices of
planning and budgeting manual is also
book that you did that's right that's a
book that I worked on last year in
response to the need that congressional
offices found themselves in subsequent
to the gramm-rudman bill that was a very
interesting time normally congressional
offices are exempt from the effects of
members own legislation this was though
probably the one exception to the rule
and in January of 1986 members King
members and their staff came back from
the Christmas break and they found that
their own office
had been dramatically reduced and
suddenly they had to make some very hard
management decisions about what to stop
doing what to cut back on we did this
study to help them cope with that
problem mr. Lumis when a newly elected
Congress person comes to Washington
there's a tremendous number of issues
that they have to face what's the
biggest problem that they have I think
that the very large number of things
they have they have to deal with I think
that that they may have had several
issues come up in their campaign they
may have worried about particular things
in Iowa in a farm State and California
where the water or what have you when
you get to Washington you find that not
only your local concerns are there but
there are myriad other policy concerns
and then on top of that you have around
a million dollars worth of resources to
put together to form into some kind of
organization as well and perhaps finally
but but most importantly this is a
tremendous personal disruption in your
life you're taking children out of
school you are changing careers for a
spouse perhaps and so at the very time
you are organizing yourself very
difficult time trying to focus on new
issues you're also having perhaps the
most difficult time of your life in
terms of personal dislocation all in all
the if it was they had a stress list of
stress tests it would they would be off
the charts and in how much stress was on
the members of Congress joining us now
is Deborah's sake hey whose idea
actually brought about this book she is
president of the inter-american
foundation and you were once a candidate
for Congress but you've lost in the
primary I'm told and at that point who
approached American University with the
idea of this management guide for
incoming members and you were named to
the inter-american foundation in
September of 1984 what were the concerns
that you had originally that caused you
to bring this idea to American well my
concern is a taxpayer getting our
money's worth and getting it as soon as
possible
and since when I ran for Congress I was
already 60 I was not on a ladder I was
trying to see what is it I really could
use my skills I'd been a businesswoman
and what could I do that would be useful
so I spent some time talking to
congressmen and I realized not only was
the job so complicated but it sometimes
took two terms before in the second term
they were really got it the first term
was sort of on-the-job training and it
seemed very expensive to me and never
has the world situation been so complex
never has the needs have been so great
and we need very skilled people and we
need them right away so when I started
looking at Congress I said hey this is
you know manuals we use them in business
you use them to similar Tinkertoys how
do you get things done without a manual
and there wasn't one I got all the
literature League Republican Party put
out all the literature the Democratic
Party put out that was on reelection I
got the various other centers and with
the exception of a small bit of
information that Congress itself put out
more about locations and there was no
sort of thing what do you pay a
secretary
what do you pay this how do you set up
your mail you know the day you arrived
in Congress there's Saxon Saxon you know
there's just nothing I was amazed it was
very proud to see the two editions are
already out well it's been fun and we've
had so many congressman aspects two
copies and to me that's proof somebody
that needs it or wants it I our guests
will be taking your calls but not for
about another 20 minutes we'll be
discussing this issue and then taking a
call from an expert on the subject and
we'll put the numbers up a little bit
later on during the show and we start
taking calls about 20 minutes one of the
things in looking through the notes on
the book is that strikes you is that you
think or I think the general public
perceives that once the election is over
in November the ballots are counted
you're declared the winner then it's a
little vacation time and then you go to
Washington and get started and that's
not the case you mentioned to really be
influential you have to forget about the
vacation for a while and come right here
to Washington what do you do then well
first of all you have to hoe
that your election really has been
resolved perhaps the most painful
situation is a contested election that
drags on for five or six weeks or even
months as we had in 84 and when you
really don't know which way to turn but
assuming as in the majority of cases
that you you you do have your seat and
there's no question about it one of the
phrases that we use over and over in
this book is that you you really have to
hit the ground running where do you
start over and over what we emphasize in
this book is that a member must start
with a clear sense of his or her
priorities the toughest question for a
newly elected member of Congress is what
will they not attempt to do in their
first term their constituents will put a
lot of pressure on them to do many
different things interest groups will
put pressure on them the administration
their party etc and to some degree of
course they have to be responsive to all
of these things but if they are not
going to just become if they're going to
avoid finding them in themselves in a
situation where they are just responding
reactively to this that and the other
thing that hits them they have to work
out a proactive agenda and that takes
some thought and they have to spend a
little time with their key advisors with
people who they trust and work out a
clear agenda for their first term one of
the things you mentioned though is not
necessarily bring the campaign staff to
Washington to become your congressional
staff could you explain that yeah I
think that I think that there's an
assumption that well you just bring your
campaign manager and plop him or her
down the a a job administrative
assistant job and you're off and which
is the top job that's how you will be
ordinarily the top job in a
congressional office and I think our
position is that you shouldn't discount
that possibility sometimes that is
exactly the right person for the job but
that shouldn't it should not be anything
automatic perhaps someone with a lot
more experience on Capitol Hill someone
that you may not even know might might
be the perfect the perfect person
again as just as we talk about
individual priorities we talk about the
notion that although there are a lot of
similarities every individual member has
to do it his or her way there are there
are idiosyncratic parts to this job both
in terms of constituencies and in terms
of the 435 individuals who represent
those individual constituencies so I
think that priorities is correct and the
second thing that I would the other P is
personnel finding that one does one or
two persons fairly quickly you may not
have to staff everyone but you may want
to get the one or two people you can
trust and here's where the campaign does
help you might not bring your campaign
manager but you may have a personal
secretary who you can trust completely
if not may not want to come to
Washington she might want to come for
several months and just help you get
things going so I think there are about
as many models as there are members of
Congress I take it then it would be a
good thing to find one or two key people
to get that office started as you
mentioned the Congress person should not
be the office manager should not be
really running the office but that
should be delegated and then perhaps to
turn to try to get committee assignments
that obviously is first because that's
what's so exciting is what you're doing
and not only for your constituents but
your involvement in government and the
plum committees go first so as soon as
you arrive you know before anything that
really is the priority because that's
what sets the tone of your whole career
if you begin to think you know the
country is so complex and you can know a
little bit about a lot but there is a
few things you need to specialize in and
focus on and getting your committee
assignment is the key and getting what
fits what blends with your own
enthusiasms and your own interests and
then as you set up your office you
really need some professional management
to help set it up and this is what the
guides about because you don't have it
and you can't afford to have it you need
to be able to set up so that once the
office is said it's going and then you
can focus on being a common
how do you get those committee
assignments you get off the train or you
arrive here by car you land at National
Airport your office is moving along what
do you do next and there are there are
any number of stories about campaigns
and that really all is right there the
farthest reaches of this book we talk
about that but clearly the the best
wisdom there is often within the the
cloak rooms with between sitting members
of Congress but the stories are
Allegiant I think what what is crucially
important is to have supporters in high
places to touch our touch all the bases
and it's extremely important not only
for the committee's that you get because
that's where you'll be working for the
next couple of years at least but if you
do get good committee assignments that
gives you an aura of succeeding already
in the process and allows you as mr.
Seki said to become the member to be to
serve as the congressman not to worry
four months later about whether or not
your press secretary isn't doing exactly
the right things in time and time again
in the book we talked about allowing the
member to do only the things that a
member can do the first thing only a
member can do is to get committee
assignments a staffer can't get you a
committee assignment you have to do that
yourself but if you're not worried about
so much worried about how your office is
being staffed you can go out and devote
that attention that's the key I think in
terms of one of the keys in terms of
office organization how about the role
the press secretary committee
assignments or one thing of course press
secretary can get your name a good press
secretary can get your name in front of
you know with those two year terms free
elections always there but even their
press secretary has to be thought of in
terms of your management strategy for
example if you come from a media market
where there's so much there's there are
so many members and senators in your
media market for example Los Angeles or
New York as a freshman member you're
unlikely to be able
to get on the airwaves so you're gonna
have to look for someone who can
communicate through print who couldn't
send out for you very good newsletters
that go to they your constituents door
that will be read on the other hand if
you come from a small community where
you're big news you want someone who's
familiar with the local media market the
the electronic media market in your area
so you have to work out your strategy
and then pick your personnel rather than
do it the other way around
for example one of the people we
interviewed in 1982 for the book
we interviewed freshman in 1982 to talk
about conditions for freshmen
subsequently was in a safe district he
knew that once elected he could stay
there he got the nomination so he had
already come to Washington he wanted to
be relatively close to the floor he
wanted to be he knew he wanted to be a
very public congressman he knew that in
October and he had a lot of foresight he
had a lot of time and he did more or
less those things got himself a press
secretary that could get that helped him
get that attention so to the extent that
you can plan have the luxury of time
you're helped greatly now starting in
1972 most of the newly elected members
of Congress before they actually took
the oath of office started going back to
school up at Harvard University in
Cambridge Massachusetts and the head of
that Pope program
Paul beaux grad is joining us now by
phone from Massachusetts at his home I
believe Paul ER there
apparently Paul is not there well he
will be joining us in a few minutes
Jim I'd like to make a point about the
administrative assistant position as
Burdette has already mentioned it's a
key decision and many members are going
to make that decision based on their
perception of the their the potential a
is political savvy either of their
district or of the hill rarely are they
going to choose an administrative system
based on their management credentials
and yet if the member is not going to be
drawn down into the office management
in most cases that administrative
assistant has to have a pretty good
sense of management and therefore not
only does the member of Congress need a
book like setting course but even more
so the administrative assistant and the
other key staff that middle management
special on needs a real earnest training
program on how to help the member
through effective management within the
office I think mr. beau grad is on the
line now mr. Boger are you there yes sir
okay you're calling from home in Boston
right
we like to first ask how did the program
at Harvard get started well it started
originally by a congressional staff
member who was a fellow at the Institute
of Politics who thought that there there
might be the possibility of developing a
an institutional program to to introduce
new members to public policy questions
and they started off very informally in
1972 I believe I think was just four
members I think the next year in 74 it
became a little more formalized and
structured with the Committee on house
administration and just move forward
from there since that time we've had
about it's almost 60 percent of the new
members have attended the program you
could talk us briefly through a typical
program is that Foreign Affair is
domestic and a little bit more about
that well it's some aspects which have
have been in the program every year and
then there's some that obviously reflect
current current needs but it's pretty
much across the board it is both
economic structure overall economic
policy budget process then moving into
into certain domestic questions
agricultural policy certain social
welfare questions and then into foreign
policy both institutional foreign policy
relationships between the Congress and
the executive between Congress and and
foreign governments and then area
questions Middle East southern Asia
Central America depending obviously on
on the immediacy of the of the question
who are some of the speakers that would
be addressing the new members in our
most recent program they they
generically are tend to be a mix of both
academics and practitioners if we were
leaning in one direction of the other
it's on the practitioner and what we try
to do is bring sort of a combination of
the two in the most recent program we
had people like Paul Volcker people like
Elizabeth Dole people like former
commander of the US military SOUTHCOM
Warren Nutting and academics like I
guess Bill Kaufman and Bob Murray who
are in the national security programs at
the Kennedy School Bob rice is an
economist at the Kennedy School there
are it's not limited to Harvard by any
means I guess of the academics oh maybe
two-thirds are from institutions away
from Harvard what is the what is the
stated objective of the program I guess
what I'm looking for is what message do
you want to get out to the new member to
convince him or heard who would come up
to Harvard well we try to do is to give
them a basic foundation on the kinds of
public policy questions they're gonna
have to deal with we divided up
essentially into three three basic goals
one is to try and lay out for the new
members the basic and prevalent schools
of thought on a very issue to try and
lay out for them the constituencies that
they will have to deal with about that
issue whether it be the constituents
they'll deal with in Washington the
constituencies they'll deal with back in
their districts and the constituencies
that will will play upon the issue both
nationally in
nationally if the third thing we try to
do is to to lay out for them the the the
legislative expectations and initiatives
that they are going to have to deal with
immediately when they take office there
there are sort of two sub goals that
that fall into that and they are they
are goals that are in some ways
secondary to those first three and that
is to begin to assist the new members in
developing networks of expertise on
issues and beyond that to try to and
this is the most difficult for us to try
to get them to look at public policy
questions a little bit in the national
perspective in other words to try and
remove themselves if not physically at
least intellectually and emotionally
from the boiling pot of Washington if
you will and step back a little bit and
have a national overview on issues mr.
Lumis you have a question yeah mr.
Berger at Burdette Loomis I wondered if
you could comment on how well-informed
your sense that the newly elected
members of Congress are and if you've
been around long enough up there whether
it's been a changeover over the last
several generations of new members let
me say that this is the first year that
I directed the program but I've had the
opportunity to talk fairly extensively
with people who've been involved in
program in the past but let me say this
that the experience and knowledge of the
members varies and it varies not only
from member to member of a from issue to
issue we've had members who attend this
program who know as much if not more
about a particular issue than some of
the presenters but we're dealing with
not just one issue we're dealing with
the broad spectrum of public policy
questions and and therefore you don't be
very rarely you very rarely get a member
who thinks that anything that that's
presented to them is something they
already knew so I guess it's not a
specific answer your question but but at
the realm of their experience in
which does vary it's generally pretty
good though I think they know the
questions they want to ask and that's
important that's probably the most
important thing about the program
remember they're here for six days and
it's pretty intense program I mean I
frankly I don't know that I could deal
with it they go from 8:00 in the morning
till 9:00 at night
there are 15-minute breaks between
sessions the the meal sessions for the
most part are working sessions but even
with that intense program you can't hope
to try and deal with the myriad of
public policy questions that they're
going to face in my new detail and so we
try to give them a basic understanding
of it and help them formulate the
questions that they're going to have to
deal with as they make their decisions
about voting from year to year this
year's class seemed to have a stronger
base of political experience we had
number of people who were officeholders
legislative executives mayor's County
officials and even those who did not
have specific political office
experience seem to have a we were quite
impressed with the sophistication about
public policy even those who some may
have suggested or at least by their
occupation they would have questioned
their their understanding of public
policy we're in many ways the most
oppressive you have a question yeah one
mr. Bogart we met also with the freshman
class and we're very impressed I think
this is one of the best qualified
freshman class that Congress has had in
a long time and we expect great things I
just wonder whether that's six days very
intensive course how much stays with
them do you do any follow-up
well our follow-up is informal we are
not in the business of grading members
nor are we in the business of of
evaluating them what we do talk to them
fairly extensively in terms of
evaluation of what we're doing as to
much help it is of the specific
information
III tend to agree with you you're not
sure how much stays with them it is
pretty intense
they are also leaving here and going
into a very intensive both emotionally
intensive intellectually intensive new
experience taking office so what what we
hope that we do with this program and we
think we've been pretty successful is
they begin to have an understanding of
the world in which each of these public
policy issues live beyond that they
start to develop the kinds of
relationships between and amongst them
that form the basis for their working
relationships relationships in the
Congress we've had a number of members
who have come back to talk to the new
members who are alumni of our program
who say to them that the most important
relationships that they that they've
experienced during their terms in
Congress were the relationships that
they developed with their fellow
freshmen that year I think Paul Tsongas
former senator from Massachusetts was
one of the presenters this year that was
a one of the pieces of advice that he
gave was that those that became his
strongest allies and friends in the
Congress were those who were part of his
freshman class and I think this is one
of the this is one of the first steps
that they begin that they get in
developing those relationships I've been
particularly interested and I wondered
we in our management manual do not talk
policy or politics we're totally
nonpartisan we talk state management how
to set up your office and we don't tell
you how to think and we assume the
congressman comes fairly well-equipped
and Harvard and all the various schools
help them to a great deal but I've
always thought that Congress ought to
have a night school several nights a
week in Congress available for the
various aids some special courses for
congressmen quits what do you think
could such a program be combined be able
to teach policy be able to do
to management to be able to teach all
the different angles so that they'd also
have some place they can go and ask
questions well I suppose it could one of
the things that we are are considering
and actually will probably do for the
first time this year is to begin to
offer a series of refreshers so to speak
about public policy courses for the
alumni of our program as to whether you
can mix management and public policy
management of their congressional
offices I'm not sure it's a being a
member of the House of Representatives
is so such a politically intense
experience electoral II politically
intense they are dealing with running
for election every two years some say
they'd never stopped never had the
opportunity to do much beside run for
reelection and and I think they've got
to figure out individually how to deal
with that how to deal with the
management of their office the the
political / electoral management of
their of their office and I think that
that to try and mix the questions of
public policy with that and obviously
these two are interrelated but I think
it's the job of the member of the
elected official to balance the two
I would be very hesitant I think to to
have this this permanent structure of
Washington and of of the legislative
process meaning people like our program
people like legislative staff people
like lobbyists etc to try to usurp any
of that that's the ultimate judgment
about any member of the House as they
are the ones the most balanced public
policy and electoral political demands
mr. Loomis has a closing question are
just more of an observation and that
that we're really talking about two
sides of representation here one side is
a policy representation the other side
is how you manage your office resources
and although we don't talk explicitly
about reelection there's no question
that how you organize your mail how your
computer system works is very much
electoral related
is how you approach public policy
questions that they're talking about at
Harvard so the notion of of
representation is multi-faceted and it's
the minutes it is the end of the
individual member of Congress who has to
keep coming back to that notion of how
he or she wants to represent day in day
out and one last thought to tie this
together I agree with mr. Bogra that
it's a members job to work out the
balance here but as Deborah psyche has
pointed out we're not suggesting
enforcing some sort of training for
members or even staff but providing the
facilities we feel that that is what is
lacking and that is what's very very
needed in such a complex environment OBO
Gradney yeah closing thoughts well I
wanted to agree with the last point I
think one of the things that we are very
careful about is to be an honest broker
in all this is to leave the sort of the
political and so-called moral
philosopher just philosophical judgments
to the members they were elected to do
just that we try to be a very
straightforward as unbiased as
individuals can be a broker of thought
about public policy and I think that's
very important especially for this this
permanent part of the legislative
process I guess that's what how we look
at this program we've been it's very
rewarding for us to have the opportunity
to present this to the new members and
what we get back we think it's been
pretty valuable for them thank you very
much for joining us okay well thank you
okay stay warm up there I will be taking
your calls in just a few moments the
numbers will be listed at the bottom of
the screen throughout the show and we'll
give them to you once here at the top in
the eastern and central time zones it's
202 six to eight twenty five twenty five
six to eight twenty five twenty five and
any Pacific and mountain regions it's
202 seven eight three 27 27 783 27 27
those calls will be take
we'll be taking those calls in just a
few moments first thing I want to get
back to is the importance of committee
assignments we'd like tackle Alan why is
that so important to her remember his
career well in the House of
Representatives in particular we're
talking about the house here only
perhaps a little less important in the
Senate but but in the house
you're talking about 435 members if
you're going to tackle any question you
can't decide with all 435 and so the
work goes on in committee so Woodrow
Wilson's observation 100 years ago true
today it may be a bit less true there
may be more abilities to freelance
partially because there are so many
resources in each congressional office
but the fact remains that by and large
the average rank-and-file member of
Congress spends more time doing
committee work in substantive committee
work than any other kind of substantive
work and so it reflects on your
reelection if you're from a farm state
you obviously might want to have an
agriculture committee if you are
interested you have energy problems you
might want to go into Energy and
Commerce and and clearly beyond that
there are power committees
appropriations budget Ways and Means
rules that can clearly benefit any
member and increasingly in an era in
which the budget and appropriations take
have taken on such a large role a larger
even that then perhaps ten years ago in
a six hundred billion dollar package
last year being on an appropriations
committee in our Budget Committee may
mean that that your district can have a
scrap of a pork or a needed program you
know you call it what you will
you're able to fold that in whereas you
couldn't perhaps do that if you're
sitting on education and labor or
judiciary very important committees but
not so close to the money how often does
it happen that a representative comes to
Congress and is from say in agriculture
but does not get on the AG committee and
he is forced or not forced but he ends
up with an assignment that he really
doesn't know much about and now he's
faced with two years on that committee
the best stories here are stories about
when you've got lemons you make lemonade
the best stories are really in Reverse
shirley chisholm was put on the
Agriculture Committee from a New York
City
congressional district she squawked and
she left the the committee subsequently
a Freddy Richmond a New York
representative year later was placed on
agriculture he looked at agriculture and
so you can look at this as a farm
committee from one point of view
turn it around it's a consumers
committee and he was very effective in
making consumer points he also made it a
point to visit farm communities and then
have representatives from farm
communities visit him back in the
district his district attorney district
I think that with a few exceptions most
members get committees that if that's
not their first choice they're
compatible with they can they can make
some good points they can do good things
for their constituents they can interest
themselves and then if they want to move
on to a money committee a power
committee later on they can do that many
of them quickly become subcommittee
chairs and build power that way
let me just add briefly that should it
happen that a member from an
agricultural district does not get on
the agricultural committee they do have
the other option of carving out a niche
for themselves in one of the caucuses
the cotton and rice caucus or something
like this where they can clearly show
their constituents that they are
representing their interests that are an
active player our first calls from
Oklahoma City Oklahoma
you're on okay go ahead what's going on
up there
a layperson out here watching the House
floor every day and didn't know any more
about the terms and procedures and what
most of us know we would enjoy the house
proceedings very much and for if we
could view it as a youth chess game with
search maneuvering going on by the
political parties or the individuals but
when they bring up bills in different
ways we don't understand why they do
this maybe it's really cannot add an
amendment or various maneuvers but if we
could have a little book as such as the
lady hey to you well that would explain
the difference terms
so how legislation is presented to the
house for there were certainly an ant's
our enjoyment of watching the procedures
of the House of Representatives harder
than of anyone there is a book I'm told
that's gavel-to-gavel guide our meaning
of greeting this off the screen here
maybe if you can stay on the line for a
bit our production assistant inside can
pick this up and give you this
information but there are some pamphlets
available that will help you understand
yes as a matter of fact we're familiar
with gavel-to-gavel chooses c-span
publication and we occasionally use it
when we are asked to speak to groups
particularly we sometimes work with
members of foreign legislators who want
to try to understand how our Congress
works and one of the tools that we find
is helpful is that booklet
gavel-to-gavel I think the caller is
making an excellent point though it is a
two-way street the representational
democracy and we really need to make
efforts both to educate our members on
the issues and on their procedures and
on their management technologies they
need to know and we need to take real
pains to make sure that our viewers our
constituents our citizens can follow the
workings of Congress I make another
point about how men were to Congress
learn these very things we
because that's one thing that a few
state legislators may have a sense of
how it's going to go but the rules are
different it used to be that one of the
key pieces of advice is what it would
have been to go in the floor sit down
spend a lot of time your first few
months on the floor just listening to
the debate and that's still not bad
advice but televising the Congress tell
especially the house has meant that you
can monitor proceedings regularly and I
think that by almost by osmosis or
throughout a question you asked what was
going on there you members pick this up
and you find this when you're
interviewing them talking to them
they'll keep one eye or half an eye on
the television set you it may be just
droning in the background all of a
sudden something will go on they'll stop
and they'll pay attention for a minute
see what's going on and come back so
televising their house my sense is that
although it's had a great impact in the
country it's also had a tremendous
impact on the members of Congress and
their styles themselves they can follow
the action much better than they used to
be able to one of the things I think is
very difficult for people just watching
and the house proceedings is when the
members debate the rule which then will
govern the debate of a particular bill
if you could one of you like to tackle
that in the house aside from a few
privileged classes of legislation every
bill must have a rule or go through some
other procedure where you might need to
enlarge my majority for most important
pieces of legislation you need a rule
granted by the Rules Committee so that
often there's first a vote on the rule
in other words setting up the ground
rules for debate only then does that
debate take place the house compared to
the Senate is a relatively orderly place
that that will evoke much much laughter
but but it's it's a it is relatively
orderly a procedures are relatively
orderly and the the key vote often is on
the
of granting the rule for debate if you
want if you have a controversial
proposal you might not want to vote
against that but rather vote against the
rule my next call is from Hampton New
Hampshire you're on Oklahoma I found
that as a sporadic viewer perhaps
turning on the Proceedings of the house
or sometimes the Senate and catching
something in the middle or when there
are extended to generally dead periods
of time it would be extremely helpful
it's somehow c-span could provide some
override narration obviously on a
nonpartisan basis of just what's going
on what may be going on particularly
when they're involved Parliament area
maneuvers or particular questions about
the rule and some of them get very
complex obviously they're they're
complex to some of the members there and
mind-boggling to deal directly it is
tough we do try to run some explanatory
crawls under there it's it is tough to
do because what may seem totally
objective to one side may not be that
way to the other because to to some
people perhaps a particular
parliamentary maneuver is just that and
someone else it's blocking legislation
and they think that it's against the
rules so that's very tough to do we do
try to do that and we will continue
would you like to add anything
I think perhaps if you had someone who
was trained as a parliamentarian and had
who has to take that even-handed
approach professionally working out
you're you're subtitles there you might
get away with it one of the problems we
would have if you tried to do an audio
narration over the house proceedings or
the Senate proceedings is that you never
know when someone is going to say
something so you might try to say
something and interrupt somebody and of
course we don't interrupt anything that
is being said on the floor override that
so that's the problem with the audio
narration but it is an it is an
extremely difficult procedure
to follow one time where that might come
into play would be in the in the periods
during a vote when you might be able to
relatively briefly summarize what what
the issues are there that are being that
are being voted upon that's possible in
the house but I'll tell you what happens
in the Senate when we tried that at one
point you get complaints from people
calling in saying I didn't hear how my
particular senator voted and so it's a
very difficult situation but we're
forever working on it as it is a large
problem whitney lake florida you're on
lady lake lady lake okay right question
is the fact that the president seemed to
catch all the health of the budget and
the question i have for the members of
Congress particularly the house
representatives they have the sole power
to appropriate money and if they wanted
to cut the president's defense budget
they could do so if they wanted to raise
taxes they can do so so why does the
president catch all the golf as far as
overspending well I'm gonna that is a
good question for members of Congress
unfortunately we don't have any members
of Congress here if you'd like to just
take a crack at that very quickly
organizationally part of the problem
with Congress is it's it's so diverse
that it's hard to focus attention even
on a budget committee everyone can say
I'm not totally responsible the
president may not be totally responsible
but he is a much clearer target both I
would say for attacks and when Quinn
cret when credit is is granted as well
it also the fact that the president
presents the budget to Congress and it
is first labeled his budget
who did the I wanna get back to the book
who did the research on this book well
it was a collaborative effort Burdette
and myself and the other authors listed
did all of the research who did you talk
to basically well there was an extensive
interview process which was conducted of
the class of 82 I believe
and the Congressional Management
Foundation is constantly conducting
surveys at different levels of the
congressional office for example in the
back of this book you have a couple of
appendices one of them is a survey of
what are the typical job descriptions
found in a congressional office they
vary but one of the typical descriptions
and how much do you normally pay for
that type of service in an office this
allows a member and an administrative
assistant to work out a salary policy
which previously was just a hit-and-miss
affair another example is a survey which
asks each which asked each office and
over 200 offices over half the Congress
responded to these how do you deal with
personnel policies such as sick leave
vacation time maternity leave at a
congressional office level this is up to
the individual member so really I think
that this book reflects probably the
input from several hundred congressional
offices an American University helped a
great deal and we have number of
graduate students I ran into one of them
when I was waiting to see a congressman
there was somebody waiting ahead it was
one of the students doing the survey my
next call is from the island of hawai'i
you're on yes hi my name is Jodi Connor
and I grew up with Burdette illumise and
middle Pennsylvania I'm over here to
medical meeting and I just want to say
hello I don't know your past is
continually haunting you in one way or
another well thank you very much for
calling in fine
find a set that has audio how long did
it take from when you first had the idea
of putting this book together you went
to a you till it came out we had her
dead within how many months 60 days 30
days we've Anna
right right right
American universe yo yes because I
wanted to have it that in one year I
study actually did the whole thing in a
year was it right full year right right
and we started and ran an ad wanting
someone to head a research team what did
the ad say sounded like more or less
like my resume at the time so I thought
that I was probably reasonably well
qualified for that before the position
but it was it was really a boat out of
the blue and people when you talk to
people in the hill the the first they
were very surprised and then not always
but usually gratified that someone was
there was doing this this sort of thing
I think that there was a kind of
amazement that that someone was willing
to put the substantial resources that
went into the first volume of this of
this book that were they're willing to
put that that kind of an outlay out yeah
I think that I would like to take this
opportunity to give Deborah's a key
tremendous credit I mean here you have a
billion dollar institution which didn't
provide itself with the manual now she
came along and in the best
entrepreneurial spirit said well let's
just do it and and and she managed the
resources and and she's done this
actually in several fields
she is really committed to management
training for the betterment of
government now I would like to say
something about the deadlines that we
worked under the book was actually flown
in on election night in 1984 this was
the first edition of the book we got
that book into the hands of each newly
elected member within a few days after
they were elected what transpired was
that this was a critical window of
opportunity because frankly a member of
Congress usually will not read a book
this large I think we really felt in our
heart of hearts that it would be
delegated to an aide to read it and
apply the principles but because it
arrived before anything else really
hit the congressman's desk the member
alexdodd
tremendous delight and surprise we found
that most or at least many or the
majority actually read it cover-to-cover
extra copies and some even twice so we
repeated that this year for the
hundredth Congress and got this current
edition out within 48 hours after
election day and again found the same
response that is a critical time for a
newly elected member what are the major
changes from the first addition to this
edition well there's several Burdett
conducted a survey about eighteen months
after the first addition to the survey
was designed to evaluate what aspects of
the orientation process were
particularly useful to members of
Congress and I'm glad to say that the
book setting course rank right up there
is first on the list it also asked them
what were the areas of real difficulty
that they that they experienced despite
having the book and and one of the
things that came up very high on the
list was trying to computerize their
offices this is a tremendously complex
task when you really not sufficiently
apprised of what your needs are going to
be we totally revised the chapter on how
to computerize your office we resurveyed
the freshman class found out all the
pitfalls that we could and hopefully
have for war in this new class and we'll
see in about a year when we survey them
again next New York the president says
no all the Democrats say yes say no is
there anything in the curriculum that
helps the Democrat or
the congressman making a political
decision not know it's really
non-political it is neither Democratic
and Republican what it does is teach
them something about time management so
they have time to study the issue that's
really what they need to be able to say
yes or no not that they're Democrats and
not that they're Republicans but what is
the issue what is their gut feeling what
is their constituents interested and
when the office is well run you have
time you have really time to look at
both sides and consider the options and
I think exactly what the caller is
speaking about is the most important you
know that's the essence of what the
management manual is all about I think
you've got to really understand the
resources available to a member of
Congress we're talking now about a staff
organization that the salaries are over
$400,000 how many people in this eight
there can be 18 for a member of the
House and personal staff 18 full-time
staff members for part-time plus them
interns if you include subcommittee
staff full committee staff it can get
considerably larger if we talk about a
personal office around 15 to 20 usually
split part in the district part in in in
Washington but what's happened as the
staff resources have grown is that most
younger members some the mid seventies
on have used many more of their
resources to hire and legislative
assistants and I think that they're they
are consistently better informed on a
wide range of issues because of these
resources now in the end that they still
may make decisions based on partisan
grounds on grounds relative to their own
constituencies or what-have-you but for
the most part I I don't think these are
our knee-jerk kind of decisions and
again the point comes back if you have
these resources you should manage them
well enough so you can take advantage of
the talent is there and the considerable
talent available to
a legislator in his office claremont
california your next yes you're on yes
I'd like to ask about the sizes of the
staff of the congressman how the money
is appropriated to pay this staff which
congressman have the largest staff and
which have the smallest and I'd like to
hang up and listen to your answer in the
house you have to remember that each
member of Congress is representing more
or less the same number of constituents
so they are allocated roughly equal
resources nearly identical resources
it's very different in the Senate but
let's talk about the house here each
member receives us two pools of money
one is a pool of money to pay their
staff and another to run the office they
each get the same amount of money with
which to pay their staff there is a
rather complex formula which I'll avoid
boring you with at this time on how the
money that they have to operate their
offices with are is arrived at as a
result of this uniformity of size of
constituency on the whole and of
resources you really can't talk in terms
of which member has the largest staff or
the smallest staff they really do fall
within a similar grouping you can talk
about some things like how many district
offices does emember have some only feel
the need to maintain one district office
another perhaps from a rural area of
large the western area my take might
have five different district offices
he or she still has the same number of
staff they're just spread more thinly
Fort Wayne Indiana excuse me I gotta get
wrong button push Fort Wayne Indiana
you're next
hi I was wondering if any of your guests
at scene last night's show with Vitaly
Churkin the first secretary from the
Soviet embassy and whether some of the
congressional staff people should
study his manner he was so smooth it was
incredible
and his free propaganda platform just
boggled my mind from denying use of toy
explosives dolls in Afghanistan to
saying things like Russia doesn't need
to have a student exchange program
because their schools are so good they
don't need to do it I'll hang up unless
thank you thank you car I don't think
anyway unfortunately we one of your
chapters in here is called the ebb and
flow of mail how important is
constituent mail you're the writer and
you don't get an answer it's important
yeah I'm that IRA answers more of this
because it's more of his baby but every
congressional office has their horror
story within mail I wrote in the sand so
what happened to my response well and
the calls come in and it's the if you do
if you're a congressman and you do a
favor for someone and you get them you
get good response
you're your hero if you don't respond it
redounds to your your your liability I I
agree fully of course and and as
Burdette says the horror stories
Allegiant I think that it's very very
important to keep in mind the
fundamental what are we talking about
we're talking about representational
democracy these are the folks who are
representing their constituents mail is
a way of letting the representative know
how you want to be represented it cannot
have enough emphasis placed on it Lake
Geneva Ohio you're next
that's what Geneva Wisconsin oh okay
I gather your guests have a certain
sympathy towards large office staffs I
don't know if that's correct or not but
my comment is I have to admit that I
have a certain hostility towards Laura
large congressional office staff and
here's why
in the last election only six incumbents
you know loss re-election bids and I
would say barely 25 we even received
credible challenges and what I want your
guests to do is comment on
my opinion that large office staffs tend
to give incumbents a tremendous
advantage in an election if you know
about $400,000 worth and it's scare
tends to scare off credible challengers
and then the issues that need to be
talked about during the fall elections
really aren't discussed like they should
be and I'll hang up mr. Loomis
all right first I'll give you a
political science II a brief Monaco
science the answer and that is the that
the political scientists following this
have really failed to fund smoking gun
here that they've looked and looked and
there's no simple answer that staff
helps in or any of these resources are
statistically linked once saying that of
course the the the specter of I would
say a million dollar a year Enterprise
went to fold in Frank and privileges and
everything else is is a tremendous it
can be a tremendous barrier there's
there's no question about that and I
think it's a balancing question in terms
of doing your representational job as
opposed to encourage encouraging
challenges in terms of political reality
my sense is that members of Congress are
not likely to reduce their staffs in the
near future if that's the case I think
we should be very careful about making
campaign finance reforms that might
limit challengers expenditures as well
as incumbents because it as distasteful
as it may seem the best way to win may
be to spend a lot of money next calls
from Manhattan you're on Queens New York
and I'm a case worker for the newly
elected congressman for H Lee and I
would like to have copies of the book
sent to me and also any other
information that could possibly help me
in my new endeavor I'd like to address
that caller you first of all you have my
sympathy I'll tell you why I say that I
think that caseworkers job is one of the
most important jobs and keeping people
particularly in an area like yours I'm
sure
keeping them in the system if they're
having trouble with the tremendous red
tape that the bureaucracy can spit out
you are there helping the member of
Congress as a last resort for that
constituent who needs some help and as
you you either already know or will soon
find out some of your constituents are
going to have some pretty desperate
plights that they're coming to you with
and you want to do an excellent job for
them both because it's going to help you
member politically and for the
humanitarian reasons unbelievably there
is no manual which exists which tells
you how you can do your job it's one of
the things the congressional management
foundation hopes to be able to find the
resources to produce over the next year
or two we think it's a very very serious
omission let me tell you though that the
Congressional Research Service does have
what they call their district state
staff Institute whereby you can come to
Washington for three days and get a
fairly intense overview of how to do
your job as a caseworker and I highly
suggest you take advantage of that at
the earliest opportunity
caller you're still in the line I thank
you is there a number where he could
also call to me contact you about
getting this particular book yes we can
be reached at 202 five four six oh one
hundred as a matter of fact I might say
one other thing at this point if we're
talking about orientation books either
for newly for new staff or for interns
or people who may be coming to
Washington we have another book that's
called the congressional intern handbook
it's the book that many offices hand to
their new staff or to their interns
which provide them with a quick overview
of how does a congressional office work
and how does the hill work and where are
your research resources located this is
a book that really is the right the
right book for somebody who's not
actually setting up an entire
congressional office but needs to know
how to operate within one or on the hill
our next call is from Cheyenne Wyoming
you're on
back in 97 Congress when I was in
college I see the Senate at that time we
came out the conclusion that each member
of Congress cost the nation 1.5 million
dollars I just wanted you know anything
about 99 and how the Congress how much
they're gonna cut them how much it costs
the nation how much it cost the nation
roughly about a million dollars the
congressman he said a million five
million was winner when I was studying
it yeah
I just think that you you add everything
up the staff salaries the office space
the the trips home franking privileges
it quickly gets to it gets to a million
dollars the question here is is to
separate out the office from the member
you of course you can't and so that you
can you can figure out that he's a
member does cost us so much but it's
part of a representational system and it
may help those people get on that but
the efficiency of what we get for the
million dollars is what particularly
interesting to me because you know these
435 members that's 435 million dollars
and maybe more if you figure the cost of
the everything you know that's quite a
lovely building Congress and everything
and if you look at the sin at all and
that's why government has to be more
productive and it has to get rid of
unnecessary red tape and become more
efficient and I'm one of these people
who look forward to a four-year term for
congressman so that they really have
time to make their mark so we can at the
taxpayer can know and see and know what
we're voting for I think it would be
easier to campaign against a congressman
after four years and after two when the
problems is the incumbent gets the name
recognition as they enlarge the Senate
terms and perhaps the presidential terms
but nobody's looking at those things
this is a very expensive thing that is
not really a 'td and some way whether
the manual is intended to make this part
smoother but I would hope it's the first
of many
studies it was intended really to be a
seed not the final product IRA
yeah I'd also like to add one thought to
the cost of maintaining a member of
Congress we have a trillion dollar
government and Congress is spending
something like I don't even think it's
one I think it's 1/10 of 1% of the cost
of our whole budget in my view the
center the federal government in
Washington is very much like a central
brain it's it's kind of a central brain
for the body politic it somehow has to
get messages from the extremities of the
body politic back to Washington and the
member of Congress is really the vehicle
that performs this function those
members are going back to their home
districts three weekends at a for for 3
or 4 days they're going out to Alaska
they're going to Spokane they are taking
the pulse of the nation and they're
coming back and they're saying you folks
here within the Beltway aren't listening
well enough here's what hurts here's
what the needs are here's what the
desires are then the task becomes how do
we coordinate this it's it's money well
spent to both enable these members to
stay in communication with their
constituents and then to help them do it
effectively how much of that though is
to get the word and bring it back to
Washington versus the problems of a
two-year term having to be out there
campaigning i I think you know that
obviously there's the political factor
as well it's one of these things that
become very very difficult to separate
you can almost say well we really
shouldn't provide management training to
these members because it becomes an
incumbent advantage well what do we want
them to do perform inefficiently with
our taxpayers dollars and calls Austin
Texas you're on alright thank you
my name is Ben Knight I'm a retired US
Army Master Sergeant and I have two
questions or two-part questions one is
do you know of any registered lobbyists
in the Congress or Senate that are
lobbyists for a communist nation and
secondly who sponsored the legislation
or was it ever legislated to repeal the
death penalty
T&S panache when there was no war on and
I'll hang up and listen I'm not
qualified to answer this this is the
short answer is I don't I don't know the
answer to either either of those those
questions all I kind of doubt that
anyone lobbies for a communist nation
although it might it's certainly
possible I mean I it's not it's not
outside the realm realm of possibility
well even the Soviet embassy dough does
have people that are on the hill
of course that goaded various
congressional office certainly and for
example the People's Republic of China
made PR agent may you will have a PR
agent so to that degree the answer is
it's also and I also think that yeah a
lot of what we're talking about here is
we have a extremely open permeable
system here and it causes some
inefficiencies on a lot of problems but
it's the one that seems to work pretty
well I'm sorry we don't have an answer
for the second part of your question
Manteca California Iran yes sir good
evening I'm calling about the proposed
salaries for congressman and federal
employees they increase okay go right
ahead they get their congressmen and
federal employees to stay with this
salaries they have my opinions they
would work for nothing
because why would they go ahead that
means the mains are down for reelection
and they'll be sorry they're getting if
it wasn't that their benefits would make
more than make up for their salary how
can they propose such a great increase
when they give us their Social Security
the lousy 1% or return military or 3%
thanks to all I have to say thank you
I really I think that enough words have
been spilled in ink I spilled on the
understand the salary increase in the
variety in a variety of ways I'm not
sure how much we'll be able to add to it
myself my sense is that the caller makes
a very good point it would be surprised
I think it would be instructive to learn
how many individual members of Congress
lose money annually serving I've
interviewed a lot of members of Congress
and when I talk about this that one
constant refrain that's not really a
complaint it's an observation is that
their net worth has declined every word
every year they've been in Congress now
that doesn't mean if they get out they
couldn't increase that net worth
dramatically if they wanted to my said
my sense is that that this is a job that
if we were going to be fair about
probably is a management policymaking
job in the hundred and thirty thousand
dollar arena that's not going to happen
political reality dictates against that
and it will be a fascinating decision on
Monday and Tuesday to see if the house
will attack this or let it slide through
House Speaker Jim Wright did say they
would schedule a definite up or down
vote on the pay raise issue for you said
Monday or Tuesday or sometimes the
beginning of the week given at college
is going to Congress is so like going to
college it's an investment in your
future
our next calls from Chapel Hill North
Carolina
you're on political connections what is
the best way to go about getting a job
on Capitol Hill for example how does one
become a caseworker or legislative
assistant let me adjust that first of
all the competition is really tough each
of our newly elected members of Congress
typically will find about two thousand
resumes under their door and it can be
under any door under their door at home
or here people are very competitive
about getting jobs for members of
Congress so there are a lot of
reasons that people want to serve and
I'm sure you can identify with some of
them how do you go about getting a job
well there's a another book that that we
publish which might help you it's called
an insider's guide to finding a job on
Capitol Hill it gives kind of a world of
advice on this subject which I don't
think we have time to explore in any
great detail essentially though you want
to find out what kind of a network of
people you know that might be able to
make your credential stand out and be
brought to the members attention who you
wish to work for and you may have to be
pretty creative about that but I suggest
that the best answer is get a hold of
this book can they get that book at the
congressional management yes they can if
we could put that address back up on the
screen we headed up earlier for the
congressional management foundation and
call if you can just continue there it
is right there if you could copy that
down and ask for the lock capital jobs I
tell you one thing it does have to move
to Washington that's what I did and I
read in the paper where the president of
foundation that I now head was fired I
said oh there's an opening there's all
kinds of ways next calls for San Diego
California
you're on paying for the Democrats get
together down in Greenbrier West
Virginia it's a tax payers paying for it
I'm sure it isn't I don't know but I
don't believe so does anyone here have
any more information on that are but I
would doubt it I don't have the the
actual facts on this but I'm it is very
unlikely and I believe the party is
picking up the tab one of the sub
chapters in your book here talks about a
sense of during the first term a sense
of mission where are we going
could you tell us a bit more about that
I think that a congressman has a
marvelous opportunity contribute to
where we're going and that is a very an
understanding and
opportunity to not only make his own
mark but to add something to not only
our government but to the world and he
or she has that you know god-given
chance to make a difference
whatever path he or she takes it is
possible not to go down just a committee
role of course everyone has assigned to
a committee but also work for a powerful
position within the party could you just
elaborate a little bit on that I think
that when you ironically when you're
talking about party service we often
think of committees is waiting and
waiting committee actually you can
probably have an impact in committee
relatively quickly if you study hard
carve out an area of expertise and move
ahead in many ways it is party service
that takes the longer time in part
because party service takes for a long
time a long stewardship and involved Jim
Wright
for example served in the house for 32
years before coming incoming speaker but
also you have to gain the trust of your
of your friends something that the Paul
burger had talked about beginning in
these informal sessions that's extremely
important and so I think that although
someone might come to the house with the
desire to be a party leader I think Tony
Coelho probably did I suspect that
that's something of us a bit unusual
that more frequently once you get here
you learn that you can get along well
you learn you can do things and you you
take that kind of an opportunity so I
suspect that's something that you
develop into within a term or two and
the caucuses and developing expertise in
different areas you know really reading
up and studying up and being able to
contribute people pay attention Chicago
you're on oh speaking of the efficiency
and I historical to it I was just
wondering 200 years ago I wonder if they
even thought about the national
government paying for representatives
from the state I think it would be a lot
better
Oh rod more efficient if the represents
work honorable to the state rep the
state finance Congress we're talking
about the state yeah I call you're still
in line right caller you still what
exactly do you mean in the state finance
Congress well right now you're talking
about a million dollars for each
representative it's taken out of the
federal budget why wouldn't I want to be
better if they were paid by the state
and the state can campaign they whatever
run a peg bonuses there we pop up
against something from time to time here
like the four-year term that's in the
current we're talking about
constitutional issues and the
Constitution has something to say about
members of Congress not what they're
paid but they establish these positions
and I think that that to try and create
innovations like this is probably it's
just just figuring in in the air so some
of my sense is that I'd hate to be on
the floor and try to argue trying to are
trying to talk about a Utah paying
someone less than than the California
what have you Red Bluff California
you're on you're on okay discussion
about those pay raise congressional pay
raise and there's the thing that I've
never been one that I've been wanting to
know okay they keep getting a raise all
the time they vote themselves a raise
when they retired they get to the same
face but what percentage of it do they
get after the Ricard there's a lot of
people that served a lot for the
government basically the Armed Forces
which gives nothing happy retirement
and I would like to know just exactly
what for said he's the congressman get
in retirement thank you all right I
don't have the exact figures here but I
don't believe the caller's correct the
military have quite a substantial
retirement but if they retire they have
to put in 20 years if they retire under
20 years I don't think they get anything
is that right not correct I think
Congress is sort of similar it's have to
be quite a long talk it's five years and
then after after five years it's
prorated as you as you gain in in
seniority
I think perhaps up to 20 I'm not sure if
after 20 that increases at all but it
it's a it's a regular pension plan that
the government puts in that then the
congressmen contribute and we wouldn't
want to set a 20-year minimum because a
lot of folks would argue one more
turnover do the staff members get the
same type of pain there is there is a
plan available yes government there's
government pension plans too right New
York City Your Honor I would just like
to say that the news reports I heard
today February 1st where the Greenbrier
was paid by a private foundation not by
the Democratic Party although the
foundation was not otherwise identified
but my question is as I study the
Constitution on this 200th birthday it
my conclusion is that the framers
thought that a two-year term for
Congress was generated because of the
human condition and human nature and
they it was pretty tough in those days
to travel a lot tougher than it is today
and I wonder if the lady would when I
was explained a little bit more why she
thinks about for years is good when
we've had two years old as time and that
was the I think the original intent be
coming not from a political judgment but
from a judgment on human beings and
lastly what's the best way for an
individual to get their congressman's
attention and to get their
representative to work
for him thanks a lot enjoy your show
thank you well the first ones to me and
I'll let someone else pick up the other
one the onus of reelection has become so
complex in this time of media and so
expensive that campaigning for
reelection is a whole different game and
the amounts of money spent 200 years ago
for election or reelection that you
can't even compare I don't know what it
costs then but it's a whole different
game and you can see how it's multiplied
and the idea is you'd be able to pay
more attention to government and less
attention to re-election and as how to
get best attention of your Congressman
is to know him to work for him to work
for his election then if you call him
he'll answer well also members of
Congress take a great pride in
representing all of their constituents
not only those who voted for them
although I clearly they may have an
advantage their members of Congress make
themselves terribly available these days
I think that you can find out and your
members schedule you can find out when
he or she is having town meetings you
can go to those town meetings ask your
questions if you have a personal problem
you have the caseworker who you can work
with on a very intimate basis if you
have an idea for a legislative
initiative you can articulate it
concisely and perhaps with a one-page
cover letter and then all of your
supporting evidence that would make sure
that your letter is seriously read and
if you can peek the member and his
legislative assistants interest they
then can start going through your
documentation we're just about out of
time I just want to show the book one
more time and get a close-up on it here
it's called setting course a
congressional management guide and it's
by American University's Center for
congressional and presidential studies
and the congressional management
foundation like to thank everyone for
being here Deborah's sake a president of
the inter-american foundation Burdette
Loomis chairman of the political science
department at the University of Kansas
and I hope you have more snow than we
have here
have more trouble getting around than we
do know how could that be an IRA calif
executive director of the congressional
management foundation that last caller
who mentioned people getting around
hasn't been in washington lately and
thank you for your calls and for joining
us good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you'd like more information about
this or any other c-span program please
feel free to write to us our address is
400 North Capitol Street Northwest
Washington DC 2 0 0 0 1
[Music]
[Music]